the forming episode of fofo is
classified ma it contains some course
language some nudity drunk references a
sex scene time travel terrible Batman
impersonations at Charlie Clausen
pronounced Clausen shaped hole and mild
course language fo fum advisors that the
program is not suitable for persons
under the age of 15 and minors must be
accompanied by an adult guardian or
priest this is John deke speaking
[Music]
[Applause]
so I'm just gonna record this bit even
though we haven't started yet turn that
mic check but as I explained the podcast
to you because sometimes there are new
listeners there will be people who tuned
in I like them like check with a story
right exactly so the idea this podcast
is called fo fo fo-fo p fo fo
right now that's because it's a spin-off
of a podcast called Toph Optio fop now
that's the podcast that my friend
Charlie and I have been doing for nearly
eight years now alright and we started
it out together just as this bit of
nonsense it's called Toph op it's a it's
a stupid joke about Russell Crowe's band
Russel Crowe has a band called and they
were called tow fog and I was obsessed
with this music career and so the little
joke was that we were naming our podcast
stuff the Russell Crowe's band and the
greatest moment in the history of the
podcast was when on Google search now if
you put in T ough if it comes up first
our podcast is bad right so anyway I'm
here just stop doing the podcast right
it's a long story
yeah just stop doing those Russell Crowe
he threatened him yeah just stop doing
the podcast because he was on a very
family-friendly Australian TV show
called home it away Wow
and so at the start they didn't really
understand what podcasting was and they
thought you know we were having
conversations about things that perhaps
weren't family-friendly so they asked if
he could not do the podcast for a while
so then I span off this podcast fo pop
where I would have guessed Charlie's so
everyone who sits in that seat is
technically I guess Charlie is what we
said well I tried to explain to you in a
really short way and then realize it
makes even less I like it I appreciate
that you think so highly of me that you
would take the time to explain that so
you're not worried about the
consequences of Australian morality
outraged by the things you say your your
friend step down from the podcast right
I mean I did are you worried about your
career I did think at the time that it
was with it by manager hadn't given me a
call you know man like I host the very
popular show on the national broadcaster
the ABC and yet apparently the nonsense
that comes out of my mouth on this
podcast is to be expected of me so yeah
I think this is well I don't think
anybody's gotta go
in Turkey Wow I don't know I don't know
if I can abuse it I'm sure there are
things I could say on this podcast that
would get me into trouble but in a
general sense the things that I would
say that would get me into trouble have
already been said and people have
already made their peace with whether
they enjoy my things or not and they've
just moved on one way or the other it
seems anyway let's start the podcast it
all sounds good hello and welcome to
fofo I'm Will Anderson and joining me
guess Charlie Clausen for the very first
time but it's an absolute pleasure to
have him here he's at my house we're in
Sydney the Sun has come out the dogs are
sitting on the map behind us it is Tom
Rhodes hello Tom hey well I'm glad we
finally got to do this I know we've been
talking about doing it but in LA yeah
when we've tried for a long time to
coordinate podcast recording but Envy is
the primary source of unhappiness and
I'm gonna try not to be envious of the
magnificent little beach bungalow that
you have well I appreciate that it's
very nice of you to say I work from home
so this is all I have I don't have like
an office I go to or anything that's
more exciting this is pretty much it's
the transition from the house to the
little shed out the back of the house
that's my whole world I love it I mean
I'm staying in the inner city and this
is what you expect to see when you come
to Australia you know somebody who lives
by the water right okay no ice might
have you enjoying the inner city of
Sydney though because you're out doing
shows in Australia are you just doing
Sydney are you just at the Sydney Comedy
Store
yeah I just own the store I'm doing an
hour solo show September 2nd and then
this Sydney Festival tour which has been
at the Comedy Store and then I'm doing
Wollongong good I actually went up on my
toes when I pronounced that well did not
get Wollongong yeah it was like a like I
guess a back stretching exercise that
like you're a yoga pose I imagine if
you've gone to yoga and they're going in
it's time for us to do the Wollongong
because it's like one of those words
it's a little on a mana pack you know it
sounds like what it is it felt like you
were alone gating your body because the
word Wollongong itself
yeah it sounds like one of the poses I
could do properly right yeah yeah okay I
like that so I saw you going on this
tour you go to the guys next weekend oh
yeah
the last week I'm here I can Wollongong
Newcastle tell me this so you're out of
here at the moment so you're doing your
hour which I highly recommend people go
and see if I am in town I'm definitely
gonna come along on Saturday night if
will liked me I must be funny yeah
exactly right that's what that basically
that's what I was doing Tong that was my
little endorsement the top get to the
show details early in case they you know
switch off before yeah yeah sorry but
the other nights you do these you know
amazing sort of lineup shows they have
there at the store this is the way
they've been running their shows around
the Sydney Comedy Store which is the
kind of a showcase of the best of you
know young and emerging you know Sydney
comedy with like you know some
experienced people some internationals
some you know drop ins you know it's a
real good mix if you go out for another
comedy there plus you know people doing
these hour-long shows sort of around it
tell me about like doing those lineup
shows because when you a comedian of
your experience you know when you go out
on the road often you're doing your set
every night like whether it be your
headlining yeah you're not working with
a large variety right and you do yet you
you're probably there you know you might
have like two other people on the bill
you know like in a general sort of sense
you know you might have a host you might
have like a someone who's gonna like
feature for you but that's essentially
your whole crew and then suddenly you
dropped in with like 12 people who all
kind of know each other probably as well
or know each other a little bit more
than you know them like what's that like
as I'm just interested in the you know
the skill of being a comedian that is
beyond the actual bit you get to do on
stage which is the changing circumstance
of your job how are you in those
situations I like it um I like I love
comedy it's my favourite topic and thing
activity in the world and I like seeing
different styles of comedy there was
some great local acts that were on the
show everybody's doing 15 minutes and
this store has been packed though I I
think I'm not just blowing smoke up your
ass but yeah it's playing in Sydney's
one of my
favorite audiences Sydney Sydney company
stores a great comedy room I think one
of the best comedy clubs in the world
and that's why I sometimes those rooms
just have like a magic that you can't
explain because if you were gonna design
it it's not perfectly designed like you
know there's still bits of it that you
would ideally change but for whatever
reason there's something about that room
particularly when it's full though the
oval stage the height of it the red
curtain and then in the the back part
it's tiered seating so like everywhere
is a great seat and you're right it's
it's not like the perfectly designed
room but I love it and then also what
you're saying about working with
different comedians I'm in Los Angeles
now I'm on the road half the time and
then half the time I'm in LA doing sets
at the Comedy Store and The Improv and
it's like that everybody's there's a ton
of comedians
everybody's one 15-minute sets and then
I also go to New York City twice a year
to do sets at the Comedy Cellar
and the underground and that's everybody
doing 15-minute sets and as you know in
London it's the same those kind of I
mean it's you know there there was there
was one act that was a complete flop
over the weekend there's a couple of
younger comedians great character people
you could see they're just starting to
write their comedic voices and they had
really strong jokes as it is I mean so
like for me it was it by the way I think
it's undervalued as long as the flop
doesn't ruin the die exactly it's
undervalued how good a flop can be for
the rest of the night yeah because
essentially what it is it's essentially
somebody falling off the high wire
before you go on to do your high wire
yeah like there's a sense of going oh
yeah this is dangerous
this isn't that easy to do like I feel
like it should almost be necessary for
every night if you're programming you're
not perfectly you'd be like look it took
me honest it's unfair to them and
they'll appreciate this backstage time
but we've put them in we'll put them in
the flop spot club spot just to remind
everybody this is hard some of these
guys are making it look too easy I like
it and then also there's a
you know there's there's an art to doing
a short set like when you do a
television set you're doing like seven
to ten minutes and you know they're
gonna chop it down to five or sometimes
you only get five and you got to hit it
perfectly like an Olympic dive so I'm
interested in that because you say you
you are interested in comedy and you
love comedy so it might be something
that you have like a nice insight into
which is this idea of in five minutes
what are you trying to achieve
like if someone says to you hey we want
you to come on Conan or whatever or you
know do this gala spot or whatever it is
but it has to be five minutes what's
your approach to doing five minutes as
opposed to doing like you know our
headline set well I mean of course
you're just gonna try and hit them with
as many jokes as you can I mean that's a
you know or a like the greatest story
five minutes is nothing but like when
you're talking about the 15 minutes set
like when you do you know Montreal the
gala or these other festivals and it's
always at the gala you do like 15
minutes and that is like I think a
perfect amount of time to to showcase
your best jokes cut all the fat off the
porkchop you know hit them with your
best story whatever you can really like
you know build a nice crescendo in a
15-minute said I absolutely agree with
you which is that opportunity in 15
minutes is enough to introduce yourself
fully to a crowd if you do it properly
like tell them everything that they need
to know about you to go away and have
like a fully formed opinion of you in
five minutes you can give them an aspect
of your personality or who you are or
your thoughts but you can't give them 15
you probably should be able to give them
enough of an indication about what the
rest of the 45 minutes would be if they
came and saw you for an hour you know so
what is it in that 15 minutes that you
would like an audience to take away from
you like if they're seeing you for the
first time what are you trying to come
across in 15 minutes so that they walk
away and go well this is what I think of
Tom roads sorry I mean I'm trying to I'm
trying to do my not only the funniest
jokes the smartest jokes right okay and
then and then also
personal flavor of like like Bill Hicks
used to say about Jerry Seinfeld well
he's funny but you don't learn anything
about him right it's just all these
jokes and you know I don't I don't do a
big personal bloodletting onstage I
don't like that either you know like the
the Edinboro show or someone cries every
night exactly at 28 minutes and 30
seconds right you know and once it's a
harder recreate this model you know it's
hard to have one of those things happen
to you every year you might have one in
you like it's like going yeah coming
home at Christmas and trying to get dad
drunk so he'll touch you funny so you
can cry the one thing for my comedy
career yeah yeah I I did Edinboro a
couple years ago and I called my uncle
immediately and said had you [ __ ] me
all right I would add a better shot at
least joke at least got on the list list
well that's the thing these days though
as well with that style you know comedy
I've noticed is like in the past there
was at least an aspect of and by the way
I've seen people write powerful shows
around you know those sort of themes it
only becomes a cliche because there are
now so many people doing comedy that
everybody feels like they have to have
one of those sort of shows and then
sometimes people don't have a story that
really matches it with the other story
yeah it's like I'm a dog died and I
really like my dog yeah well man I don't
like I don't like sloppy comedy if I
like well-written comedy and like if
you're doing a 15-minute set like you
should show the the best that you have
to offer even on like Edinboro hour
shows or any kind of show I like to I
like to be dazzled by a little wit I
like to be as impressed with someone's
intelligence of what they can you know
articulate in a humorous way so who
wasn't that inspired you to be a
comedian like that like who was it that
you were fascinated by that was like oh
I you know these are the things that
thrill me when I watch them or when I
want to be a comedian these are the
things I would like to be able to do
well where I'm starting from my father
is the reason I'm a comedian my dad
loved stand-up comedy and Richard Pryor
was his favorite really so my dad had
tons of prior vinyl records and then he
also had Bob Newhart he was a big fan of
Bob Newhart and I remember driving
around with my dad as a kid listening to
two prior like cassette tapes and so
that's where I'm starting from and
Pryor's my all-time favorite and then
when I was real young starting out in
Florida I worked with Bill Hicks and and
then I moved to San Francisco on my
spiritual comedy quest and I've always
thought that San Francisco is the
Jerusalem of stand-up comedy I think it
started Mark Twain invented the stand-up
comedy art form he gave lectures the
first one was like 1856 something like
that in San Francisco and they were
humorous he worked on these lectures
like a comedian he dropped lines that
weren't funny the guy you know I think
invented stand-up comedy there so I
liked I liked the idea that my view is
doing some open mics on the white of
those gigs as well haha before he got me
in front of the new saloon
yeah you know Samuel Clemens is doing a
gig wink later on tonight
always Andres usually working name just
while he's trying it out okay if we
could get the piano player to stop
playing some ragtime for a second and if
we could get those those drunk
prostitutes at the pool table to simmer
down just a little bit we're gonna have
some comedic entertainment by Samuel
Clemens wait till a guy with the peg leg
makes his way across the wooden floor
before we start so so I mean so I I
started out with high standards and and
then I've through the years you know the
the comedy world is very small so like
doing festivals and you do it for any
number of years
I mean everybody pretty much knows each
other you know I'm friends with Dave
Chappelle and and louis c.k and bill
burr and Doug Stanhope and all these you
know you know brilliant comedians that I
see and get to hang out with so it's
like so not only you know I always have
that that's really like in America now
is the Golden Age of comedy the there's
such a resurgence and there's just the
best of the best of American comedians
I'm working with in in New York in LA
and and and doing these like 15-minute
sets and seeing how they do it can I can
i per Gail you were the weather with a
with a story about Amy Schumer I was in
New York in June I went there for a week
yeah and oh it was great my some friends
of ours own a place right on Bowery so
it's like really it's right next to
Little Italy and then there's Greenwich
Village so it was a short walk you know
we'd have my wife and I would eat like
these great restaurants that she yelped
and then we'd stroll over to the club
and the thing that those those those
shows like if somebody famous comes in
and they want to go on they go on
e-media right and you get bumped so
twice I got bumped for Amy Schumer
she told this story about about her dad
she closed her set with saying you know
my dad has MS her dad as someone of the
terrible muscle disease and he's
wheelchair-bound I think it's MS and he
said that he's a real mean person he's
kind of an [ __ ] but she's got a lot
of money now and she wants to do
something nice for her dad because she
loves him so she has been paying someone
to jack off her father and she's like do
you guys think that's wrong and then
like half the audience like no and
they're they they you know it's New York
they adore Amy Schumer so like I had to
go on after her
and I I was I had I improvised this
great opening I would walk out all
sheepish and I'd I'd say hi everybody
forgive me I'm a little nervous this
isn't my real job my real job is hijack
off Amy Schumer's father right yeah I'm
not used to working under these bright
lights usually I worked a candle light
with a little soft Sinatra in the
background
it was it was great so tell me this you
talked about like you know being in San
Francisco and those sort of spiritual
connection between sort of like you know
comedy and what I mean it's an
interesting thing comedy to do as a job
I think about this a lot and one of the
things that comes with being a comedian
is the if you allow yourself you can
constantly be in your own head like
you've signed up to a job where you have
given yourself the capacity to every day
wake up and examine your life and
examine the circumstance around you and
examine what you believe about the world
and like soak up what other people
believe about the world and try to
filter that into like you know a way of
connecting with a whole bunch of
complete strangers in a room it can be a
great thing to sign your life to like it
can be about what comedy can teach you
about life and as a coping mechanism and
all those sort of things but it can also
be that sort of thing of going you know
the comedic angle on this is when
something terrible is happening I
sometimes wonder if I'm connecting with
it in the way that I should be because
I'm actually connecting with it in the
way of going this will make great
material you know that you process your
entire life through the prism of what it
means to be a stand-up comedian so I
guess the question I'm asking you is how
connected are those two things to you
like the journey of what comedy can
teach you about who it is to be human or
is that something that is separate you
know to the work do you separate those
two how does that work do you understand
the question I'm asking well I uh it's a
it's a it's a two-tiered question so
I'll give you a two-tiered answer I
think the thing about staying in your
head is a good thing it can be taxing
yes of course
and my wife is a great coach about
pushing me you know how do you feel
about this how do you feel about that
and like did to to write essays we both
feel that like writing little mini
essays is the is the path to writing
great material okay
and the you know were my uncle used to
deliver packages for Federal Express and
he would always say to me you know Tom
just remember when I show up at an
office building to deliver a package
no one applauds you know I can comedy
and we get a week we get applaud before
we start before it's that we walked up
we go to work - for you people you start
your I mean they start your 40 minute
job exactly
and like ice hey now that I'm older I
wake up earlier but I used till noon
thirty years of my life but my favorite
one on that one is if I'm like if I come
home after a terrible show and by the
way most terrible shows a shows that I
believe are terrible by my stepmother
than the audience having walked away
thinking were terrible but I come home
in one of those moods like you know it's
a night in work because this you know
kick and yeah blah blah and Amy's big
one is always how long did it go for and
I was like 45 minutes she's like yeah
yeah and then it was over
so yeah you know yeah like even your
worst at work is over within their own
oh boy that's the good thing about
comedy is the job well the good you know
and so the good thing about that
perpetual voice in your head where
you're you're looking for things is you
know I always think especially as a
stand-up comedian you have to be your
own best corner man okay like Muhammad
Ali had bundini brown in his corner he
was the guy who came up with the float
like a butterfly sting like a bee poem
and so he was the guy in Ali's corner
don't don't don't give up champ keep
sticking you know stay off the ropes get
in the inside you Bob your head and
stick and throw and punch and uppercut
and you know you have to do that
yourself as a comedian you're on stage
and it's like okay this you know all
that new bit really [ __ ] the bed and I
gotta you know stay off the ropes you
know you you you and and and then in
life as a comedian you got to keep
coaching yourself back from the brink
it's the never ending thing about comedy
and what I always say about show
business in general is it's never
possible to feel good about yourself for
longer than three minutes at a time
so like you like you could have like the
greatest achievement and then like three
minutes later you get an email from your
manager a club cancelled or there's
something that you just feel like oh
yeah that's right I'm a piece of [ __ ]
so no matter how great you feel about
yourself there's always something that's
gonna come and knock it off three
minutes later or less so so I think
there's that good aspect for me about
you know we're and I like you not being
lazy and trying to like now I'm trying
to come up with my my new hour I just
put out a new album called all hail
laughter and available little places
that you buy album so do you have to go
to your website or my website Tom Rhodes
dotnet but it's on you can buy it there
or Amazon and I mean I I'm trying to
film a special my next I did a Netflix
special a few years ago it came it ran
for three years it just came down but so
it's time for me to do like another
special okay so tell me then if you're
about to like embark on that idea of
going at the end of this this is what I
want I want this new show that's gonna
be this special and yeah I put this
together how does that process work for
you where do you start you know putting
something like that together do you
think about what its gonna be as a whole
piece before you start or do you
shipping away on ideas or little things
that you have how does that process for
the next special I have an idea about
doing something internationally so I'm
gonna pitch that to Netflix in Comedy
Central when I go back to Los Angeles so
okay so you got like a thing like a
thing that yeah it would be but then
this this new album I just put out it's
a double album I recorded
Minneapolis last year it was right after
the Orlando pulsed nightclub shooting it
happened
yeah and I'm from Orlando so I got a
nice gun hunk on there and then also it
was right after Prince died and right i
prince was from minneapolis i recorded
it in minneapolis i I like long act me
or somebody asked me yeah ie
in 1995 Prince's keyboard player was a
fan of mine invited me to Paisley Park
for a private party where Prince jammed
from like 3:00 in the morning until 6:00
a.m. there were only 50 people there it
was like incredible so I talked about
about this and on that so that's - that
show was before Trump that uh I was had
recorded stuff about you know the
election on that one and then the next
one I did in San Francisco and in
February and it was right after Trump
was elected so like there's you know and
then there's personal okay so tell me
this I'm fascinated by parents I well
whatever reason where I grew up I got
the wrong idea about what Prince was
when I was a kid like in our area Prince
was kind of it was on the commercial pop
stations and it got mixed in with if you
were into commercial pop music like that
Prince was kind of like that
and so I for whatever reason in my head
just got into my head that Prince wasn't
the sort of music that I was not - I was
in LA when he did he did 20 shows in 29
oh wow yeah for him yeah and so I'm
living in LA and I go and say Paul F
Tompkins do you know Paul if - yeah yeah
I see him at Lago doing a show one night
and he talks about in his show that he's
just gone the same prints and from his
description from this like ten minute
comedy routine that he did that night I
was like whatever the [ __ ] it cost me
I'm gonna get a ticket to go and show my
friends right so I go and pay whatever
it is that I paid for this ticket one
ticket by myself and just went I'm just
gonna go I don't dude go with someone
else like cuz I'm kind of in some ways
I'm an explorer I've never
I mean of course as it turns out one of
the revelations of the night was I know
every song Prince's ever release cuz
they've you know - Prince fan Prince
songs have been everywhere enough that
there wasn't anything the whole night
where I was like what's this song but
secondly I'm so glad I went by myself
because it was spiritual it's like one
of the greatest concerts I've ever been
to
easily top five concerts I've ever been
to in my entire [ __ ] life I've never
been more entertained by one person like
the fact that he had 20,000 people just
in the palm of his hand in the round so
just have a piano on one side so you
like just go over there sometimes do the
piano once at one stage this is my foot
this is what I was like went from going
yeah okay this would be interesting - oh
my god this guy's like greatest
entertainer Wow - okay these were the
two moments that just got me where I
just went oh I get this now so at the
start he's playing on the big Jumbotron
screens James Brown like it turns out
they're a whole bunch of James Brown's
musicians playing Prince's band as well
but I didn't know that at the time
no one was explaining to me so he's
playing James Brown like in concert up
on the screen and I'm just like the
balls on this [ __ ] like that's
like me playing a Bill Hicks like live
album before I come out like it's German
like but then there's this interview in
the James Brown thing where the
interviewing James Brown and James Brown
on the big screen in close-up just says
people always say why don't you play the
best - James Brown and James Brown just
looks down the camera and goes because
the best of James Brown is yet to come
and the lights go out and Prince just
comes out from the middle of the stage
and I went oh my god all right oh geez
over on the piano and he's like playing
like the riff from cream and then he'll
play the riff from something else
and then in between your disco too many
hits it was amazing so you went to
Paisley Park is my question yeah and um
I saw Prince four times right I was in
the tenth grade when Purple Rain came
out I saw Prince in 1984 on the Purple
Reign tour and then Purple Rain
was like such a ubiquitous part of my
puberty and you know losing my virginity
it's why you know I figured that like
it's why I like INXS so much I was like
my earliest sexual experiences were like
two prints and INXS and things like just
prints I've been a fan since since
Purple Rain I saw him four times and the
the you know like did his keyboard
player Tommy who had invited me to
Paisley Park I got there early when
Saturday night right so I brought one of
the other comedians it was working with
me guys
still thanks me profusely to this day
the other comedian that was on the show
lived in Minneapolis and thought oh I'll
do this any time and whenever I see that
I saw that guy after Prince died and
he's a man so this was his keyboard
player right for Brinson he was a fan of
mine I I had done a bunch of stuff on
Comedy Central and the guy was a huge
comedy central fan and Wow and it was
one of those kind of tours so he get
there early which you know was like 1:00
in the morning right perfectly after my
show and ended like at midnight and
buzzed out there to where he lived and
he gives me this private tour then in
the basement that was yeah it was like a
purple BMW and yet there was the
motorcycle from Purple Rain which was
like kind of medium-size it looked
bigger on film you know it was like a
special made motorcycle but like oh my
god that's from the thing you know and I
saw I like to think the whole house
would like that well win it so well
before that show started he walked right
in front of me and he you know yeah he
was like five Ronnie
I mean even in his heels on stage you
could tell he was tawny but he filled a
twenty thousand say so we there was a we
I wrote on the elevator that he died on
Wow and then upstairs there was a sewing
shop with like
sewing machines and absolute beautiful
rolls of fabrics and like like Chanel
looking designs on sketch paper pinned
on on walls and cork boards and so he
actively had a designer there or he was
designing things himself all of his
clothes were made so like when I first
started taking trips to to Hong Kong I
started having like really pimp suits
made and I got it that idea from from
prints and let me just tell you because
I know you'd be impressed that I opened
for James Brown Oh girls I'd be
impressed by that
so I tell me the circumstances of this
where was it how did it happen because
this thing that's not very it happens
here as a tional II in Australia having
a comedian open for a musical act but
like a lot of the time it's when very
common in the States I knew they don't
they don't have to setup they're a band
doesn't have to you don't the move
another bands equipment right and all
you got to do is you know turn on the
microphone you don't have to pay a whole
you have to feed a whole other van
backstage yeah you don't have to like
get drinks for a whole other band
there's a lot of advantages I can say it
yeah so you're opening for James Brown
we're 1996 at the cannot die Harbor
Resort which is two hours north of San
Francisco on Clear Lake yeah absolutely
beautiful and a guy I had to do 20
minutes in front of him I've been I'm
from the South I love James Brown grew
up with I I did I started out on the
southern circuits and I remember I did a
shitty one-nighter in Augusta Georgia
when James Brown was in prison and I
rode my car out to that to the edge of
the prison and I sat on the hood I had
my James Brown Greatest Hits cassette
tape in the you know turned up in the
car I'm sitting on the hood smoking
cigarettes just brooding there got digi
Gnaeus locked up over there like animal
you know just brewed
and getting angry at government and the
you know racist justice system in
America and and and just I I know facts
about James Brown he did all of his
earliest recordings at in Cincinnati
Ohio I read his autobiography this man
means so much to me so I didn't want to
meet him right because well because if
you know things about James Brown you
might know that I have enough sense to
go well maybe this like meeting won't go
in the way that will enhance my love of
James exactly and I wanted to keep the I
mean he was in his 60s at the time his
show was still phenomenal he still did
splits and stuff and the guy is
electrifying even as a senior citizen he
was a brilliant performer but but i but
I was worried I didn't want to ruin my
my hero image I didn't want to like go
backstage
like what if he's in his underwear he's
got his wig on a hanger who knows what
the scenario my hero he's just looking
only see through his pee hole on his
boxer shorts something weird anyway just
staring into a mirror just saying over
and over the truth is I don't feel good
[Laughter]
to be quite honest if y'all know me
Frank yeah but nobody wants that as much
power if they would've been I'm feeling
soho so so you know the truth was when I
said I couldn't go on I could go on I
was just faking it go on so what happens
in that situation on the night because
this is the thing that I always think is
the comedian in me this is what I think
is like do these James Brown fans listen
to you are they because I mean I guess
they're more familiar with the idea that
a comedian might open for an act like
this so yeah and then also is Northern
California where people are really
chilled I can really cool there's happy
that something's about everything it's
hard to anger these people I got you
know
unless you like some right-wing hate
group was gonna do a march in San
Francisco and a few days ago and they
canceled it because the people in San
Francisco said they were gonna throw dog
turds at them so like we saw in
Charlottesville the clashes between the
anti-fascists and the you know the the
Nazi fascist people and that didn't
settle anything so so you can't confront
violence with violence you have to
confront hate with little tiny dog dog
turds well also you know at least you
know where all the dog turds you know
you're not gonna randomly sticking step
in a dog turd
you're probably going to encourage
people to pick up their dog turds in the
mean time so they have some ammunition
right yeah exactly so it's probably
cleaning up the city a little as well I
would think yeah there could be eco
little turd carrier ammunition bags I
did read there was some someplace which
I can't remember online that they they
had a Nazi March through their town and
their way of combating that was they
dissimilar well they signed them up to
her they did like a walkathon
yeah and they raised all this money yeah
sent it to like anti-nazi causes so that
was pretty good so every beat they
marched essentially though raising money
for causes that did not support them
which was I saw that I think that was
actually in Germany yeah you know they
have to be a bit more creative about it
now they have to lean in a little harder
like yeah I mean I would think I guess
you're in Germany now you like I guess
this is like he'd offer us a bit now
right well yeah they you know who would
have thought that now a Germany is like
one of the most progressive countries in
Europe and a very compassionate leader
in angle and Merkel and the United
States is the leading hostility I'm
interested in your perspective because
you've traveled a lot like you're a
world traveler in your comedy but you've
also lived in a whole bunch of different
places do you have any thoughts about
like what system what like what's the
things that you've seen in one place
that you can't believe they don't have
in other places do you know mean do you
have those things where you go you go to
one place and then you go why doesn't
everybody else have this
thing well yeah I lived in Amsterdam for
five writers and I did I adore the Dutch
them it's you know you you you can't
call them a socialist country because in
reality they are a socialist democracy
with a functioning monarch monarchy
right so the the the the king actually
has say an input on the government right
and Michalis but it's also a democracy
the you know the fact that they have you
know health care and like people can get
quality education for you know not
having to pay exorbitant money for it my
wife is from Rotterdam not from a
wealthy family
and she attended Leiden University which
is like the Harvard of the Netherlands
and she didn't have a crippling student
debt for the rest of her life you know
like in America I remember my sister's
student debt she had I mean there's so
many people in the states you know you
start out in the hole right Arians the
best in the broadest yeah like if the
idea of this society if the idea of the
reason to have university is is it we
vaguely agree which I'm not sure that we
do vaguely agree on this anymore but
let's just say that we used to vaguely
agree that it was in everybody's benefit
that we were all smarter right I don't
think you could actually get an
agreement on that but in the old days
that used to be the idea for - yeah less
poverty better way of life extended life
expectancy years yeah and now it's like
I mean I and I'll tell you Australia
still remains very charming to me but
like I lost the point no I tell me y'all
bet you're about to say that something's
changed in Australia from when you first
came here isn't coming here now do you
think so no that's what I was gonna say
is that in America smart is the new
stupid right I mean I don't think it's
new I think it's been as trending this
way for a while but it appears to be the
Dumber you are the better you serve
capitalism and you don't question things
you lose your
your factory job your tech job or
whatever now it's like I don't know what
the [ __ ] has happened in America well
it's what I was the point I was gonna
make no well I think that's right like I
mean I look at the news media I studied
journalism at university and like I just
look at that industry from what it was
to what it is now like I click on the
front page of these news websites some
days and I just don't see any news or
anything like I mean the news calm day
you which is the Biggio Rupert Murdoch
what mainstream Australia would probably
click on to find out what the news is
like most of its Game of Thrones [ __ ]
recaps yeah you know like you won't
believe this outrageous Game of Thrones
theory and that's like the number two
story and the number one one is about
some dwarf that fell down a hole but
their breast implants stopped them from
following the whole way down or
something that's the number one click
story then the Game of Thrones recaps
are two through nine and then you might
actually get to some politics or news
it's it's like we do we decided as a
world when it came to news that every
restaurant in the world should be
McDonald's like there's no problem with
having that trash stuff but do we have a
discussion about it or Bane trash but
the idea is that that more of us
consumed the trash though you can shame
the good stuff so I guess that's the
argument that would be made back in the
other direction yeah this is what we why
I think Australia for me remains
charming because like you guys are about
to vote on marriage equality and to me
it's just like it to me it's like I feel
nostalgic being here because I remember
when we were in that place in America
and like really Australia it's what you
who's left you Afghanistan I mean who
doesn't have what some country doesn't
have gay marriage so it's so funny to
like see this like oh that's wow that's
still an issue here yeah and that people
are making the same arguments that they
made in the States like well that's this
what's next people gonna marry their
dogs but people gonna marry their
toasters like I'm this is the exact same
[ __ ] people said in America and it's so
funny no no one's gonna marry their
[ __ ] dog or their toaster we're
talking about human beings well first a
human being experiences love and should
should have basic human rights too you
know so it's it's
just it's it's it's yes it's charming
firstly nobody's marrying their dog
right okay firstly we all know that
nobody's marrying their dog secondly
like that's not what consent is anyway a
dog can't consent to being married so
you're talking about a whole completely
different thing it's like you don't even
it's a stupid argument but even if it
wasn't a stupid argument this is the
thing that amazes me about all the
arguments whether it's like they'll do
this or any of the slippery slope
arguments that they trot out is it's
like they're ignoring the rest of the
world like pretending the rest of the
world doesn't exist you know you go no
no you can prove no one's gonna marry a
dog since 1963 no ever turned up to City
Hall with dog Hey right I could do this
huh but that's the thing with all those
arguments they'd be fine arguments if
this thing hadn't been in place
everywhere else without any of those
things becoming problematic yeah that's
funny
it just it's such a like in some way you
think Australia will be worse than that
yeah Alabama was when you know it got
passed there you know I mean it's crazy
it's but I was like this yeah that in
Australia this is a case of the
politicians being desperately out of
touch with the majority of the
Australian population the Australian the
majority of the Australian population
has in pretty much every opinion poll
for the last decade supported same-sex
or
marriage equality it's been very
political and the reason that it hasn't
got through has mostly been about
politics but I hope that it's soon gonna
I mean you know the worst thing about it
is even just as a Australian Touring
comedian internationally I can't write
like you're like oh yeah I'd like to
write something about this you know it's
a thing everybody's really excited that
ten years ago I can t really yeah I
can't be getting on stage in America God
anyway so what if people would marry a
dog they're like yeah we we did commit
me to comedy about this ten years ago
and this was an actual issue yeah well
it has been made happy by your country
that's funny my mom is a hardcore
Christian Republican and I remember
talking to her about my mom and dad had
been divorced for like 30 years and my
mom's little dog pepper is her
she absolutely loves this little dog
pepper so I was talking to my mom I said
mom you know some conservative people
are saying what's next if people really
measure people gonna marry their dogs
and my mom goes I'd marry my dog
some people would marry their dogs it is
the food it is the floor in the argument
because we all know well that's the
thing
the problem is we argue against that
slippery slope argument but we also have
to acknowledge if it were legal for
people to marry their dogs there would
be some people who would marry their hey
and I'm pretty I'm pretty fond of my
toaster well that one's no harm no foul
that's fine like you can marry it ties
it up I think yeah it's a four slicer I
have no problem with those people who
have that sexual kink that they're like
you know people get married to a wall or
like or whatever if your brain is wired
in a way that your sexual thing is that
you feel like you're in love with a wall
then better it be that then like you
know someone who can't consume or
whatever it's a wall it doesn't really
matter
do you want to [ __ ] bury your toaster
most people are thinking about love
instead of you know hate and violence
and terrorism right that's a good thing
yeah if you're like at home [ __ ] your
toast there rather than like you know
getting on online forums about how much
you hate women and then fine
[ __ ] toaster yeah I feel like that's
fine don't plug it in would be my advice
so maybe that's part of the thrill
anyway whatever
I don't know well also it's really nice
just to be in Australia and a country
that's not on the verge of Civil War
well here's the thing
so I you know I live in America half of
my time but this year I have not been
back as much as I ordinarily would be
and parties are you angry with us well
no you know what it is I feel like you
guys are having a debate about the very
essence of what it means to be America
and that's just not my debate to be had
right like I want to live in America but
it's like my America is like a couple
who always fight when we go out now and
they they you guys need to sort your
[ __ ] out and yeah and then I'll be happy
to hang out with you guys again but it's
not going to be helped by me chipping in
my two cents worth about what's gone
this is something you guys have to work
out this is America's battle about the
soul of what it means to be an American
right yeah and I think there are two
very distinct groups in that country
right now about you know that are very
very divided about what it means to be
an American and as someone who's not an
American who just wants to live in
America amongst some Americans that is
not my battle to have so I think yeah I
think I have kind of if because that's
also the area where I normally do my
best comedy he's talking about what's
going on in sort of you know my world
and the broader world right so sometimes
you're like well I can talk about what I
think about Trump or America or what's
going on but this is this is your fight
this is for you guys to talk about you
guys have got to sort this out I can't I
can't help it yeah that's a good point
well you see you seem to have a cozy set
up here it's funny you want to live in
America I want to live in Sydney well I
mean we could do a talk show I love it
yeah that's right oh man you'd love my
place for six months out of the year
that'd be perfect I love it that's like
something that comedians probably
haven't looked into as much as they
could if you could genuinely split your
schedules a little bit that's genius
it's like oh you don't really need two
solid careers yourself one guy was a
medium career and the other guy was a
decently located yeah that's all you
need to bring to the table this guy's
got a great career the other guy's got a
conveniently located apartment together
they're unstoppable all right so what
else do you do when you're in town so
what's your day like when you like you
know were you doing a comedy in Sydney
what what do you do what like how do you
feel you die well I'm perfectly located
being in Newtown because like when I
travel anywhere my hobby that I like to
do I like I like to go to used
bookstores and I like to go to used
record stores okay and so New Towns
great use bookstores I like ethnic food
I've been doing that up and down Kings
Road is there a particular ethnicity
that you would gravity is my favorite
Indian I like spicy but so yesterday
morning I woke up early to go see the
MacGregor Mayweather fight ok so so that
was exciting
the guys who worked at The Comedy Store
said they were gonna go to the Vic Vic
on the park so I stroll over the this
classic Ozzy you know pub and the place
was packed with people and I couldn't
find my friends so I had passed this
other place called the golden barley
hotel and I went in there and I watched
it by myself
I was really exciting to be in like a
room full of Australians and see it was
like half the the people wanted
MacGregor and then half the people were
for Mayweather and you know it was it
was really exciting and will you are you
a person who is excited by fighting are
you would like an MMA or like a boxing
fan in general or just more about the
spectacle of this particular event um I
you know it's funny because I'm against
violence but um I love boxing
yeah what's a great upon violence like I
mean I think there's always loves boxing
I tried to box when I was 13 for a year
in junior Gold Gloves like the movie
rocky had come out might like a lot of
white guys in America got suckered on
the movie Rocky me and my brother both
like watched Rocky and looked at each
other and thought hey we should be the
next heavyweight champions of the world
bothers about those hated them so um you
know and then I had one fight and came
in second okay so tired one fight you
know and I remember this there's alley
fights and in the 80s were incredible
Sugar Ray Leonard and and Duran and
there were so many brilliant fighters
it's the the the boxing game is kind of
waned in the last few years but I was a
real snob when UFC came out I thought it
was too animalistic and to violence and
the thing with like a guys down on the
ground another guy's got his in his he's
on his knees and his dicks in his face
and he's she's punching him haha I have
my dick in your face and I'm punching
you in the face it just first time I saw
UFC I thought are these the deleted
scenes from Shawshank Redemption it was
his too violent weird homoerotic for me
so I was a real snob and then I'm
friends with Joe Rogan and I play at the
MGM in Vegas where they do the UFC
Championships so he set me up on tickets
three times and it's like ancient Rome
gladiatorial before the TV signal goes
out to the world they the arena goes
black the who's Baba O'Riley comes on
and to that song they play this montage
on all the screens of like the greatest
UFC knockouts and and then the song
gains momentum and it you know like
three quarters into the song it starts
going bop bop bop on the drums so they
cut this montage of knockouts to these
these [ __ ] drum licks and then by
this by the time the song ends and the
lights come on and they go to the live
feed you want blood right it's absolute
bloodthirsty ancient Rome gladitoria yet
and it's exciting there's an adrenaline
to it so I really I enjoy it but the
thing that I dislike about it which you
can see from the mcgregor mayweather
fight
what happened like he was complaining
that they didn't let it go to the end
where he was knocked out why didn't you
let him knock me out on the ground
because it's not an animal sport when a
man is being seriously injured they stop
it right in UFC and I've seen it tons a
fighter is down he's been knocked out
out and they let the other fighter get
on top of them and do like this barrage
this finishing fury which is pure brain
damage right for later in life and I've
seen the women fighters probably not
notify somebody's down they got blood
coming out of their nose in her mouth
and they'll let the other fighter get
like five solid cheap shots in on them
you know wow they go okay that's it I
mean here's the thing that I would say
is if I were looking outside the world
if I were looking outside America you
know it's like an alien coming to life
and you look at where the world is now
with the madman in charge now America
you know like the craziness of it one of
the examples you would use about the
descent of the civilization with the
fact that like the biggest thing in the
world is all these people like you
essentially you know doing Thunderdome
doing blood sports do mainly the biggest
most popular sport in the world is like
a bloodsport
yeah here's the thing I don't like
boxing and I don't like MMA and but I
like I get it I'm a sporting spectacle
yeah I like a spectacle yeah and I was
intrigued and like you know I get the
theater of it and I get the fact that
they also these people like you know
despite our concerns and whatever
they've all chosen to do it and look you
might not know I mean [ __ ] maybe you
should have known if you played football
that you get concussion but you know
maybe they told you if you wear this
helmet and whatever you're gonna be fine
right we didn't know the smoking was bad
until like the eighties right you know
and your [ __ ] heart that it was bad
right actually in your heart you know II
had to tell you explicit yeah you know
yeah you knew and it's I don't think
there's anyone walking into MMA who does
not know that that is got to be
detrimental for you so I guess you know
what you're signing up for so there is a
part of me that's like well if two
people want to consent to do it yeah and
a bunch of people want to watch it then
no it is it is entertaining and like I
said I've seen it live and and and
of did its but I was a real snob about
it when it started because I was such a
boxing enthusiast so I've been converted
you're right it is the the end of
civilization high-water mark but the
thing that you need to remember I've met
a bunch of these fighters after the big
MGM thing some of them are like five
five some what there's a lot of them
they're really tiny like Mayweather was
149 pounds McGregor was 153 pounds but
that's not a very large man so you need
to always remember that when you're
somewhere out in public and some little
punk is you know you think about getting
lippy with somebody that one of these
guys could karate spin and you know kick
your jaw in a place well I mean
particularly when you look at someone
like McGregor who like what three years
ago was like whatever he's like you know
but he's mythology of McGregor from like
the little I know about this was he came
from nothing in a very short period of
time essentially Dineen like he was a
guy who like before UFC didn't have a
lot going on in his life but so he's
exactly the sort of guy who could have
been at the local pub and you could have
had a problem with I imagine he's always
had I've never seen anybody I've been
I've go to Ireland once a year out of 20
years I've never seen anyone walk around
like like that with the arm swing II and
the [ __ ] you know the the the the ass
out and chest in which is really almost
like balance wise almost impossible to
do unless you're swinging your arms like
that that's the only way to stay up just
walk in that posture this all has such
an everything I'm just a street urchin
thug walk I mean yeah
Ireland people are very funny and humble
and you know yeah it's true it's not you
it's the braggadocio is not really true
dar yes
you don't mean like a boastful [ __ ]
like that ever he is easy unique person
I would like to say a bit of that coming
and then maybe there is in this world
cuz I don't follow it close enough to
know
but I would love if the next cuz this
one seemed about boxing has to be about
you know you got floyd mayweather money
Mayweather you know the guy who owns you
know strip club and spend every night it
is yeah I see what a classy guy you know
blah blah did he build a Children's
Hospital
no no build a strip club that costs $100
to get in Wow $100 on the door just to
get in anyway it was there every night
and then Conor McGregor you know this
guy who again like you know it's built
this reputation on how brash and like
you know confident that he is is could
you be could you be like a diminutive
shy humble type and just be really good
at fighting and get to the top I guess
that's what I'm asking
like good bring in a ticket gate like
that without need to have a big
personality or would it just be enough
to be like I know right to shy polite
fighters is not gonna sell tickets you
have that many take you're absolutely
right right you're gonna have like a
bunch of you know Boy Scouts and their
grandmothers ringside right no no no
they know their time corporate CEOs who
can oh those who can afford those
[ __ ] seats you know that's like good
like 10 grand there's something are you
probably more rap moguls and yeah yeah
by with that I want the well-mannered
fighter who's trained by his grandmother
I mean essentially you are asking
somebody to make a poor life choice
because no anyways making sensible life
choices is dropping a hundred thousand
dollars to sit in the front row of like
a fight it doesn't matter who's fighting
it doesn't matter if God comes down and
fights Muhammad in a fight like a
hundred thousand dollars from pretty
much any normal person it's not a
rational decision right so they know
their target market they want people who
don't make rational or good decisions so
they want a couple of role models who
also exemplify not making rational or
good decisions so those people can
identify right that's how you want you
want a guy that a pimp or a hustler or a
guy who's gonna spend $10,000 in his
honeymoon fund to go to Vegas he's going
to identify with I love it it shows true
um we should talk about well gone well
the fight of the century okay yes
December 26th the day after Christmas
1908 1908 happened in Sydney Australia
rush cutters Bay Jack Johnson became the
first black heavyweight champion of the
world most Australians don't even know
this oh man I didn't know that and
that's that's not even though white
fighter would give a black fighter the
title shot at the title this is the
color line and Jack Johnson was coming
up Jack Johnson was from Galveston Texas
most of both of his parents were slaves
former slaves he was born right after
the end of the Civil War so Jim Jeffries
was the champ and then he retired he was
his beloved fighter like total badass
and some guy got the the title and then
this guy from Canada from Quebec named
Tommy Burns was the champ and to think
about you know how limited rights or
travel black people could do Jack
Johnson Travis followed this guy around
the world and would sit ringside and
taunt him well you should give me the
title give me a shot at the title and
Tommy Burns called him a million racial
slurs he once they followed him to Paris
all over the world
wherever he was fighting and sat
ringside I think Sydney he said bring
side also and he was as well-dressed
black man and he gets this title shot
the Tommy Burns chose some ridiculous
amount of money you know I would only
fight him if I was offered this this
Australian promoter Hume akan Tosh put
up the money for them to fight and then
no America arena would allow a black
fighter to go for this there was such
staunch embedded racism and this this
Canadian guy Tommy burns does it the
fight is on YouTube there's a there's a
brilliant documentary called
unforgivable blackness that you should
watch it's about Jack Johnson
and so he won the title in in 1908 in
Sydney the day after Christmas everybody
wanted the white boxer and Jack Johnson
just punishes this guy and he keeps
trying to fall down in Jack Johnson's
hole de novo nas gonna be a long day for
you cuz he had called him the N word so
many times and and all this [ __ ] and I
made plus he traveled around the world
white like a cat and a playing with a
with a mouse Wow and it was probably the
greatest fight of the century and it
happened in Sydney Australia
well somebody surely why oh I'm sorry I
forgot the most important detail so the
big money back then like now was the
film of the fight Tommy Burns is getting
his ass beat so bad the Sydney police
want to step in and stop it the fight
Dave they're in the 13th round they're
threatening to stop it so in the 14th
round Jack Johnson's was putting him
away and the Sydney police not only the
the the the Sydney police shut off the
cameras because they didn't want it
recorded a black man beating a white man
they shut off and you see right as the
guys falling the cameras get shut off
and apparently the Sydney police went on
to the ring supposedly and ended the
fight I mean that's an amazing story
like it's so you're having this argument
about [ __ ] statues now right
there should be a statue to Jack Johnson
at rush Carter's Bay I mean absolutely
where the old Sydney stadium used to be
yeah I mean this is I just wanted to
present that it's amazing to me I did
not believe this podcast we would end
with a call for a new statue but I think
it has I was amazing that was really
great oh yeah we should wind up because
we're gonna go back-to-back we're gonna
record your podcast as well so you know
that means that we should finish this
one and plus I want to put this up I'm
gonna put this up pretty much
immediately so that people can make sure
if they in Sydney Australia that they
come out and see your show at the Sydney
Comedy Store September 2nd at 7:15 7:15
early so but that's good 7 o'clock
that's I mean
not easy place to park you know go in
there hang out with me after this
exactly look at that you know not only
saw a show we made a friend yeah exactly
right it's nice to make a friend I feel
like you made a friend with the cab
driver yeah like the deepest
conversation with that guy I could tell
right when you got out of the cab I was
like he was like he actually gave you a
written like it was like a real-life
uber you know how you have to write the
driver at the end he rated you and he
gave you five stars but just to me cuz
he was a cab driver just like you've got
a good one here so great great look I
say even cab drivers love him guys you
should go and see him do some stand-up
comedy if you are anywhere else in the
world of course you can download his
album so hey thanks for being part of
the podcast I really appreciate it I'm
going to plug in anything from my end Oh
what about the internet and stuff can
people find you is there a bit um rose
dotnet the new album is all hail
laughter and off the podcast what's the
podcast podcast is Tom Rhodes radio
snorts camp so people can find that in
or the usual places
Tom Rhodes dotnet in your No so they at
all say look at you yeah a web site that
actually helps people not all of our
guests have that including probably like
your illustrations you have on yours
those are great uh well they say James
Bond's dark who's this brilliant
Australian artist he's from Adelaide he
does all my for all my shows now
basically because I I reached a peak
with my looks and since then photos
photos have done me no favors so
basically it's just drawings from now on
so you have to imagine how much I've
artificially inflated my good looks in
the drawings to what you'll actually see
there on the night but we are doing two
shows live at the Sydney Opera House
September 15 and September 16 charlie
myself and a whole bunch of guests will
be on those shows first show I think is
pretty much sold out there might be a
couple of random tickets second show
still some tickets available but come
along to those they're going to be
absolutely huge we'll be at the LA
podcast festival with a huge lineup as
well and you can check out all our
podcasts at TOCOM all right nice one
we'll see you later thank you Tom thank
you will
[Music]
you